that was was that you someone that got
that let's together kalyan well anyway
lunch I mean I think I would like to
request is if we could have people move
more down just take a minute to move
down so that we can have an actual
conversation come on down look yes
people are moving okay so more people
are going down great the better I don't
want to take up too much time with this
so it is my great honor to introduce our
next keynote speaker who is Kathy Kaz
early who is currently an independent
strategist working with the Hewlett
Foundation but I first met Kathy
actually when you were an independent
consultant at that time too and then
later the Hewlett Foundation had the
wisdom to bring her on as a program
officer and this was back in two
thousand to where she had the foresight
to be the original funder of the open
learning initiative at Carnegie Mellon
University and then after working at the
Hewlett Foundation really leading the
oer strategy along with mike smith for a
number of years she became CEO of
Creative Commons and now she is back
again being an independent consultant
but when we were thinking about who
should we ask to give expertise around
open educational resources I could think
of no one more perfect than Cathy
Casserly
great thank you very much for that
introduction I've known Candice a long
time along with some familiar faces I
see in the audience so it'll be fun to
reconnect so I am honored to be here to
speak about openness and talk about the
MOOCs as well because there's really
been a long journey in the open
educational resources space and it
continues to evolve and I think there's
parallel tracks with the MOOC world as
well so just to give a little bit of a
road map I want to talk a little bit
about the goals for the talk so we can
all kind of be in the same field so on
talk a little bit about the early vision
and the motivation regarding open
education resources where it came from
some lessons learned and where it's
evolved and then really talked a little
bit about open licensing Candice was
really clear when I spoke to her about
this torque that everyone may not be
familiar with open licensing and that
that would be an important thing to make
sure i was able to contribute to the
conversation and also the growth of the
oh yah movement where it began and where
it is now just not in the United States
but certainly globally to talk about how
MOOCs fit with the oer movement where is
the fit where is the overlap where isn't
there fit is this something in a
different world and a different kind of
vector as it takes off and to talk about
MOOCs openness higher education in the
future everyone's talking about it just
to really try to summarize where I think
things are going and where the
possibilities and the potential is
overall so I'm going to stop back in
2001 Candice is a right of cycle through
these independent consulting gigs
periodically I find them freeing and
this is one of those moments and I
joined so I guess part of the story is
Mike Smith is here and I can't see him
there he is and mike smith joined ulan
in 2001 is the program director for
education and a scene was thinking about
where he would spend his tenure at ulah
he realized there was not an education
technology portfolio that hadn't been an
area investment typically for ulit it
was the end of the dot-com bubble it had
burst but where was and how would
technology play an important role in
education and there's some of the early
players as well so
the question was cathing can you come on
and just hype out a little bit let's
think about where we can spend some time
in the technology space and as I fast
forward through the story I want fast
forward through all the different
projects we funded we spent a lot of
time thinking about efficacy we thought
a lot of time about thinking about
research because what we needed to know
which is what we still need to know
today is what works in the education
online environment but we also knew that
if we were going to invest in some
significant random designs at that time
by five years later when the design and
the data were back the technology was
changing so fast it would be essentially
irrelevant so we went through a process
of really trying to figure out where
would we invest and what would it look
like and one of the projects that came
to ulit and under Mike's leadership and
then mine is a program officer and then
initiative director really helped manage
and lead is the MIT OpenCourseWare so
Chuck fest president of MIT came to ulit
along with mellon foundation to support
and ask the eula foundation to fund this
idea this idea that MIT would put his
open materials cost materials out
available for the world to be able to
see and to reuse and to repurpose and so
this was the big bang those of you who
were here at that time it was like the
big bang in the knowledge universe
that's what it was called I see Vijay
Kumar and she Gary magawa who were MIT
faculty who SAT around the table in
those early days as we talked about the
beginning of what this OpenCourseWare
venture would look like and what it
would mean for the world and sharing and
the big piece of this was that this was
an institution and an elite institution
that was opening its window but very
clearly not its door so that others
could peer in and see what was inside
the ivory tower and it was huge because
the thirst for what happens inside MIT
is enormous and there was take up very
much like MOOCs the interest
particularly outside the United States
were strong but what we also learned
early in the early days that there were
a lot of workers employees in Silicon
Valley who wanted to keep up on
technology so the drawer into the
materials that were open courseware were
fascinating but a you live with that was
one core project but we were still
continuing to think about what would the
field look like so we were speaking with
Carnegie Mellon and we were meeting with
them fairly regularly and they were
doing this great working cognitive
science and we were thinking about
learning design and out of that emerged
the Carnegie Mellon open learning
initiative there was another type of a
project it wasn't just courseware but it
really is scaffold learning in all the
ways that we know open learning has been
so successful we funded lots of projects
i'm just going to showcase a few of them
at Rice University we funded a project
called connections which is now morphed
into open stacks and in the early days
of connections was really just small
bundles of knowledge that faculty or
students could bundle in ways that made
sense for them based on their prior
knowledge so that they could kind of
weave their own flexible and adaptable
pass through education we tried to rely
on networks we didn't need to build from
scratch always in the very beginning it
was what networks might we be able to
haunt us who would see the value
proposition of open educational
resources UNESCO has a huge Network and
in 2002 they convened a meeting at their
headquarters and because at that time we
wanted to know does this idea make sense
is there attraction if we build it will
people come and the resounding response
that we received at that meeting was
there was an incredible thirst
particularly from the global south who
did not have access to the textbooks to
the materials and we heard clearly that
there was an interest in a thirst from
the leaders and the education leaders of
the countries and there was a second
thing we heard clearly is that this was
not to be just content that would come
and materials from the north to the
south but the South readily wanted to
contribute back and to engage in this
process and that is something that I
think we've heard early and we tried to
hold true at the same time so it's
really a collaborative learning
environment we relied on organizations
like the Commonwealth of learning which
has a virtual University of the small
states which began to build out oer has
been a huge champion we funded OECD to
conduct studies of the surveys to
understand who where the traction was
with open education we funded the Open
University of the you
who were the premier distance based
organization at that time who had been
in kind of blending both online and
face-to-face or distance at that time
and face-to-face instruction they build
cohorts together they serve
non-traditional students they didn't
require that you had a high school
degree and yet they brought students
through a continuum and have been a huge
server of higher education in the UK we
had to start some new organizations
Monterey Institute for technology and
education was one that really focused on
the k-12 space it's me which is the
Institute for study of knowledge
management and education began to
develop the oer commons because we
needed a place to be able to find the
content and the search and the ability
to locate content and discoverability
still continues to be an issue we funded
oer africa because the hub certainly
couldn't just be in the united states
that had to be global and we needed
local entities to be able to really
support the movement and at that same
time which we weren't quite aware we
decided early on that there are lots of
things we could do in education
technology we were going to focus on
content and we're going to worry about
hardwiring schools other places other
people would take care of that and we
hadn't really had on our radar in a
significant way the IP issues but it
became very clear quickly into the
grants at MIT I think there were some of
the grant funding was for to deal with
the intellectual property issue and I
know the oh UK tells the story that
there was a line item for 125 k for
their lawyers to figure out the
intellectual property but what happened
at the same time Creative Commons was
being born and so what we heard is hey
there's someone down the street down
there stare for this guy Larry Lessig
and there's other co-founders one of
them is al hal abelson who actually
works in this building and they're
trying to think about the sharing space
so you should go talk with them so that
was one organization that you let
supported in the early days so when I
can't just ask me about this talk she
wanted she said you know go back to the
early days and what you were thinking
about and for me so you know this is my
perspective this was a very early theory
of change model it was from april two
thousand four it's what we used for our
board to justify some of our investments
and we really kind of simplified the
model
the end goal was really thinking about
equalizing access to education to really
level the playing field so that no
matter where you were geographically or
what your financial constraints were you
would have the opportunity if you had
internet connection to be able to access
this knowledge and this knowledge which
should be a very high quality so we kind
of very much started a bit on the supply
side of really trying to develop high
quality open content we knew that there
were key areas that had to be addressed
we had to remove barriers to the use of
the content we had to make sure was
facilitate an easy to use and we had to
understand and stimulate use there are
many feedback loops at different points
but all of this was really a cycle of
how we try to learn about the space and
continue to promote the growth so as you
think about open educational resources
one of the most important pieces that
you need to think about is what the open
licensing is so this is an incredibly
important part of it so I'm just going
to tell a little bit story about kind of
intellectual property in the Internet to
see to understand where we are gets
house so before 2002 there were really
just both ends of that spectrum it was
copyright anytime we create anything
anytime a creator you I an institution
creates anything in a tangible medium it
is automatically copyrighted where
there's a paragraph whether it's a
squiggle design whether it's a painting
whether it's a lesson plan whether it's
a textbook things get automatically
copyrighted we don't actually have to
put that C stamp on the document or
whatever it might be the other spectrum
is you can put things into the public
domain and you can let people know that
they're in the public domain so there
was really this this to end opportunity
either everything's under copyright or
things can be in the public domain but
then along comes the internet and now
there's space for sharing sharing copies
copies everywhere right and how did the
law begin to keep up with the technology
and with the internet and it really
wasn't happening there was no way for
Shearer's to let the world know what
they wanted and that's really the space
where creative commons was born and the
idea is you can share you the
the Creator have the freedom to choose
only if you want if by the way you want
to share it with the world and if you do
want to share with the world you can use
an open license and one of the global
standards for open licenses is Creative
Commons there are different versions of
Creative Commons licenses it's also part
of the story of the evolution of the
organization at one time it had up to 12
way too confusing cut it down to six
stable form that continues today the
first one is just that little emblem
which is everyone every all the licenses
have to have attribution whoever the
creators has to be attributed but this
variations on it the first one is called
Creative Commons by which means you put
it out to the world and you can let
anyone use it in any way they want they
just need to attribute you the Creator
the second license with a little share
like is the one that Wikipedia uses you
can take it you can reuse it revise
remix but you've got to put that back
that new product back into the world so
others can also build on it in the
future the next one is non-commercial
you anyone can use it but if they use it
for they can't use it for commercial
purposes if they want to use it for
commercial purposes they have to find
you and you have to negotiate an
agreement and the last one is just no
derivatives stays the same within kind
of the print version of it so these
licenses were born and there was an
incredible take up particularly in the
early days among the bloggers and the
photographers a lot of the culture
community really understood the value of
the licenses so when we talk about open
licensing and oer we're talking about
free all right and here we mean free
it's no cost there's no cost to use to
access the content to download it etc
but secondly then this is a really
important piece is that this permission
you automatically have permission to
reuse revise remix and redistribute so
you can take that content of materials
and you can build on it and you can
learn from it and you can you can
translate translation has always been an
important piece of it and in the oer
community there's really some important
shared values that knowledge is a public
good that open can deliver equal or
better quality resources at a lower cost
that everyone can contribute it's not
just the few and that the continuous
improvement cycle is really critical
around open resources to improve
teaching and learning and so we're
really trying to focus on the learning
outcomes so one of the pieces as the
space is evolved is not to think about
oh we are just as a product it's also
it's a process it's a way of thinking
it's a way of teaching and it's a way of
learning and I think the conversation
about this has grown particularly as a
movement has grown and really in the
goals while we implicitly previously
talked about thought about teaching and
learning it wasn't always explicit these
are the goals that come from the the
community particularly from ulit at this
point to equalize access to knowledge
for teachers and students around the
globe and to improve the practices of
teaching and learning through this
process so in the early days there were
not as many funders the idea has gained
traction I don't need necessarily need
to go through all of these but one thing
I want to call out is just kind of this
tack which is in the middle the Trade
Adjustment Assistance community act and
it was really two billion dollars this
was early in the Obama administration
and it was two billion dollars for
community colleges to develop high
quality courseware to help retrain
workers but the thing that was unusual
is the solicitation included a
requirement that the content that gets
generated and developed carries a
Creative Commons license so then the
Gates Foundation supported Creative
Commons to make sure we provided the
technical assistance to the community
colleges to really understand what that
meant and to be applying the IP
appropriately and so there's the idea
now and the understanding that once you
invest in these materials you you don't
always have to start from scratch you
can actually build on the materials that
exist and move ahead so there's been
policy decisions that have happened in
British Columbia in California some open
textbooks as well UK has picked up on
this in a very significant way their
Council of higher education just has
done a lot of research on it idrc in
Canada the research funding group has
invested in oer studies particularly in
the global south the european commission
is in
busting both in UNESCO and some MOOCs
that I'll talk about later the bottom
right corner is a research group out of
Seville which is doing research on MOOCs
as well so this has really become a
global phenomena this is really just
showing some of the projects that exist
certainly not just here in the United
States so I think we while we sit at MIT
and I think over MIT is just such a hub
of activity there's a whole world we're
in a microcosm here in the whole world
is out there and there's a lot of new
initiatives that are blooming which
include both for-profit oer projects
like boundless learning it's just
actually here in Boston which is
focusing more or less on the textbook
space wikipedia we all know that the
success overall peer-to-peer university
which is a way to continue to have
Pierce come together and share materials
and to teach each other and the open
education consortium I know Mary Lou is
here which is really a follow-on and a
build on from the MIT OpenCourseWare
there are so many universities that
wanted to do the same thing that MIT did
but they didn't understand the process
and the idea was to really create a
community of universities who could come
together and share kind of protocols and
lessons learned overall so focusing on
MOOCs I decided as i was thinking
through this talk and really trying to
compare oer in the open aspects to MOOC
that it can be difficult because there
really isn't a single definition of
MOOCs and there's a lot of variability
and particularly i think if you look on
the left hand side of the slide when the
focus on the x MOOC or the c mu where
the x MOOC really focuses more on
traditional models and scalability of
those traditional models and the seam
loop which is much more on connectedness
in community and actually the sea MOOCs
predated the x MOOCs which is
interesting which is also an interesting
part of this story but it was really the
x MOOCs that caught the the world in
some ways because of the scale and you
know x declaring it the the year of the
MOOC but i think it was at the beginning
of the MOOC as opposed to the year of
the moot because we have a lot of
learning an evolution to move ahead so
just as you think about MOOCs what does
it mean
no what is massive what is massive to
you versus massive to me can you know
can be endless but as a thousand massive
or doesn't have to be 50,000 or less
isn't there open registration is it
openly licensed or not what does open
mean in the context of a MOOC somewhere
Oh star not openly licensed a few are
you know other local cohorts do you
blend other meetups that come together
around these MOOCs so that you actually
have some of that interpersonal dynamic
other is it open entry or their stock
dates end dates where's the badging
right badging is going to be another
piece of these MOOCs what is the
certification look like what does the
badging look like could the badging be
open how do we think about that where is
the learning community and then is it
free of charge is it affordable do you
have to pay for certification etc so
there's really quite a lot of variations
of MOOC so I was thinking about it
there's you know there's different
variables and I think it's important to
call out because while there's
significant major platforms there's also
smaller platforms as well that play in
the MOOC space and they are all
experimenting with different models and
we don't yet know necessarily whether
there'll be a singular model I don't
think though I think there will be
multiple models but i think the models
are important is it access open access
or is it fee based is it a more of a
constructivist not concerned
connectedness a MOOC or is it more of an
X MOOC or will they come together it's a
non-profit or is it a for-profit is it
open license doesn't have an open
platform we know EDX is moving to open
EDX what is that what will that open
platform mean how will that evolve the
space is there a certification at the
end of mastery is there a fee for that
certification is their institutional
credit is there some sort of badging
thats related and what is the revenue
model and how might that be solved so
everyone's kind of jumping in very much
like the Silicon Valley startups gather
a lot of users will figure out the
revenue model but what will that be and
then what will the constraints be tied
to that so if we compare oer to most
MOOCs we know that all we are is free
and no cost we know this permission to
reuse revise remix and redistribute
which is sentra
to the oer principles so it really sits
from public good and the public has
access to the content most MOOCs are
free very few have kind of a low end up
front costs but that most of them are
free but they most of them are not
openly licensed very few are openly
licensed so they don't carry an open
license over all and they're ventured
back many most of them are for-profit
EDX is a non-profit but most of for prep
for profit and they seek revenue so that
is the endgame for those mooks so when
thinking about the space one challenge
and one thought that I wanted to make
sure everyone who participates can think
about is the space of between public
domain and copyright in this ability to
share this is what MOOCs provide this
ability to share on scale and
universities and faculty are the
copyright holders of their move content
they design the content you have your
instructional designers your pedagogy
you've worked hard though you are the
copyright holders and the challenge we
put forth to the MOOC platforms is that
they think about providing a range of
functionality with respect to the
copyright and that they be an option for
MOOCs to make it easy for universities
and faculty to add a Creative Commons
license if they want to if the copyright
holders choose to do so so right now the
platforms are restrictive and they don't
allow this option and so this has
actually been a conversation that's
going on for a while and we also know
that some of the universities would like
to share the content more freely some of
the faculty understand the value of that
and understand the value proposition for
it as well so I think in thinking about
MOOCs one of the ways we're seeing a
divergence of with the open educational
resource space is really the use of open
licensing and if you have to play out
what that will mean for the space going
forward this is a interesting figure
from a just populate publication that
focused on oer in MOOCs and i thought it
was interesting with respect to the
timeline and how kind of envisioned we
have the space had begun and really how
it moved so in the top left hand corner
you see oer kind of at the center being
influenced by
the open source software which is very
true there was a lot that we learned
from that community and many parallel
efforts there and you know open content
we call that the open content space
initially became the oer initiative at
you let others have picked it up in
different ways in different forms and
really extended in significant ways the
Open University open learned spurt out
of that and at the same time the MIT
OpenCourseWare really spurred out of
that as well and if you look around 2008
you begin to see the sea MOOCs emerging
this is Simon's and downs who did one of
the large initial C MOOCs where there
was a lot of engagement more facilitated
more guided not using traditional
methods online we're really using the
opportunity of kind of open source and
community and engagement to really lead
and guide the instruction methodology
and these connectedness moves continued
they continue to grow and they continued
evolved they don't tend to have the
scale of the X MOOCs but out of that
around 2010 you see the Stanford MOOC
that begins to emerge which kind of
splits off into Udacity and to Coursera
and then there's also the Stanford MOOC
that evolved that begins to blend back
in with mmit and the edx initiative and
so and then just across the top just to
let you know the Open University the UK
started an organization called
futurelearn it's actually like a
subsidiary of oh you UK they kind of
designed it away from the home
university so it would have a lot of
space for innovation would be
constrained by some of its early
practices but it includes both open
content and proprietary content so they
blended together they take they've taken
some of their open learn content and
they added it to it as well and then the
other book that I want to just call for
people's attention is the open up ed and
this is a pan-european MOOC effort that
is being funded by the European
Commission and it's just underway it
really has the principles of openness in
kind of almost all aspects that as far
as I can understand of it at this point
in time it's in car it's going to have
an open platform it's going to rely on
open licensing of the content
there'll be some sharing of the data and
so I think this is going to be a really
interesting model to follow to see how
they learn to see the experiments that
come out of it and how they begin to
share their lessons learn so I think
this is a really interesting experiment
in the MOOC space when we think about
the future we've done a lot and open
content and that world hasn't finished
but it continues to evolve and we know
the value of the open platform and I'm
sure not will be speaking about that
along among with others but that you
know that's incredible value in a value
proposition to have an open platform for
others to build on for the community to
come together for not one organization
have to have to create a loan but when
we also think about the data it's
equally important I thought Susan did a
nice job obviously this morning really
pulling out the importance of the data
and the lessons learned so this is a
great experimentation time where we're
going to be able to collect data at
scale and then so for me when I think
about openness and the data I think
about who owns the data who will have
access to the data how will the data be
shared so the whole community can learn
from it is there a place where the data
can be shared obviously paying lots of
attention to issues of privacy making
sure it's aggravating so we're not
violating any individual's personal
information but is there a way that data
can be shared and then institutions
whether they're EDX aqua Sarah or future
learn or open up ed can take that
knowledge and analyze that data and take
some lessons learn maybe back to their
home institution because not everything
needs to be shared but there's going to
be some rapid facilitation of the
learning curve that could happen if we
share the data in a much broader way and
so I think this is one of the very key
issues that we haven't thought about as
a community and we haven't thought about
how we create the scaffolding and
structure to do that part of the work at
ulit and other organizations like you is
to create an innovative space where you
can take risks but it's also a place
where you can look at the system level
right now most organizations
have to think about their project have
to think about sustainability and
staffing of their project and so in
thinking about the ecosystem and
thinking about how this ecosystem will
advance is really important to the
collective good of everyone who's
participating in the community so I
think for me I always use this term Holy
Grail I think this fully open cycle
which is what we've always had a vision
of but hadn't quite always been able to
articulate and it will continue to
evolve would be part of this very open
system that would work completely
effectively for improving learning for
our students across the globe in this
last slide I think again it's from the
gist report and I think it's important
to really think about the value
proposition and the role each of the
institutions play and thinking about
innovation and in thinking about
measures of performance which is along
there on the XX on the y-axis right time
is on the y-axis and we're moving along
and this really comes from Christensen's
work and disruption I'm with my
brother's here and he picked me up at
the airport late the other night and he
didn't hire it as well and he said I've
tired of hearing disruption in higher
education so I say this at the peril of
seeing my brother again after this talk
so it's true there's been so much hype
and we've all heard it we're all
exhausted from it it's distracting it
isn't adding to the key issues we need
to focus on with respect to learning but
in this analysis what the sustaining
innovation is really traditional
universities that's solid line and the
traditional universities serve students
who are usually in this kind of middle
to high range right the the the ones who
can afford the ones who are active
participants it's not the
non-participants that Susan's slide were
so great at showing all those highly
accomplished students but if they were
low-income actually don't participate
and go on into higher education and this
lower band at the bottom is non non
consuming customers these are people who
are not involved in higher education
because they don't have the opportunity
because they might not have the money
because they may have to go
work to support their parents and ex
siblings and also kind of to a comment
to a question this morning it tends to
and we should be thinking about people
in other countries as well right so the
take-up of MOOCs has been huge outside
the US because this is an opportunity
they are non consumers there is not an
opportunity for them to participate in
higher education and this is an avenue
for them to be able to do that and so if
you look at the dotted line it's really
what they call the disruptive innovation
it tends to be bait technology-based we
now have that technology base for it and
disruptive innovations tend to come from
new market players there's not the
traditional players it's the new market
players and so that's the cross era and
the EDX and oer which is a new market
player and it begins initially in the
lower band just to serve those non
consumers who don't have access and it
isn't always of the highest quality in
the initial phases has to be revised
adapted and proved but as it continues
to improve it moves up in the market
system and then becomes a disrupter
overall and so as we think I think about
the disadvantaged students the students
that don't have access I'm really aware
we're here at MIT but in the United
States almost fifty percent of students
go to community colleges very few
students have the luxury of coming to a
four-year residential school many others
would go maybe to the regional colleges
etc but a four-year residential program
is pretty unique in the United States
and then just be able to participate in
an elite University like MIT or Harvard
or Stanford is really a very small
percentage of high red and I think in
this country when we talk about high red
for some reason that's where our mind
always go we don't go to the Community
College and the struggle than the
innovations and the inability to help
those students succeed and I think what
we have here is the opportunity with
MOOCs with open educational resources
with forms of disruption we've
disaggregated we're beginning to
disaggregate the bundle how do we
actually rebe unda lit in a way that's
incredibly effective and how do we do it
not just to serve those two
who were already being served in doing
well but actually bringing into the fold
those students who do not have access to
education and the opportunities that mi
MIT students and others have as well so
as we think about our work I think it's
incredibly important to keep kind of the
full range of students and learners
involved we're at the very beginning it
wasn't the year of the MOOC it was the
beginning of the MOOC or the beginning
of the end of the MOOC i'm not sure what
it was in 2012 but we know this isn't
the end of the story OER has evolved
over time it will continue to evolve we
see government's picking picking it up
we see policies being implemented in
countries across the globe so there's a
thirst and there's a need and I think
through openness this incredible
innovation there's avenues for
serendipity there's the ideas get picked
up by people who can't come together
physically to a meeting like this and
continue to share and evolve so as the
MOOCs continue to grow when the
experiments continue to grow I think one
of the important pieces is that it's not
a walled garden and the data and the
knowledge really gets shared readily and
I think for the institutions who are
participating in the MOOCs is to really
think hard about what their value
proposition is for that participation
for many of the institutions higher
education institutions that jumping in
that teaching some courses on the MOOC
because right now essentially it's
trendy it's a bit of branding its market
extension opens up access but are you
going to be the solid line if you're an
institution you're going to be a solid
line well it'll be marginal difference
in marginal change but it's really the
platforms that will be pushing
disruption and then what will that mean
for the future for everyone for higher
education so I think there are lots of
questions yet to be answered and I look
forward to the conversations and
discussion with the rest of the group
for the next two days and with that I
will open it up for questions
and I understand the mics are there and
the mics are important for the live
streaming hi um thank you very much a
wonderful talk we've been big OER
supporters at mine stage i'm at Penn
State right for many many years um one
of the big issues that we're running
into with MOOCs is the big data that you
you spoke of my college within the
university has a strong oer philosophy
that seemed to kind of fall apart when
faculty were faced with opening up the
data that they were collecting with the
MOOCs they're teaching all of a sudden
there was fear we're a big research one
institution you know if I let everyone
else have access to this incredible data
set that I've now got you know they'll
all right papers that I should have been
you know that I didn't get a chance to
write what what how can we help faculty
be more open about sharing their data as
they are we sharing their content all
right so I think you know that's a great
question because it points to the
institutional constraints on which
people teach and the tenure process
exists and the tenure process has been
around for a long while and it continues
to be based on publications and what we
know is that actually there's a whole
new set of metrics that institutions can
begin to use to identify the value of
that particularly faculty person to the
larger knowledge ecosystem so as an
example I will cite like rich beranek
who was the founder of the connections
project it was a young faculty member he
was in dynamics and engineering he knew
the publishers wanted them to write a
textbook he knew by the time he wrote it
and it was published that the data would
be out of date digital signal processing
changes way too fast particularly at
that time so he wanted to put it out
into the world and let people use it and
rebe unda lit so he was a young faculty
member he took a risk because he wasn't
going to have that textbook even though
publisher had come to him
but what he was able to say is it had
been downloaded like 250,000 times have
been translated into 12 languages so the
metrics of what we use now in
institutional tenure processes needs to
mow off as part of the system on the
data I thought your question was going
first one way and then one another so
first I thought was that faculty member
worried about what the data says about
that course so you see no which is fine
we need space to fail we need space to
improve its going to be continual cycles
of it and I think for the larger issue
data as it goes back to the publishing
process so there are and not thinking of
the name but there's a project out of UK
where the scientists began to come
together to share data as a community
and there were these concerns about when
do I share data when I went don't I and
what they realized is that faculty often
in their content domains their best
thought partners aren't always in the
same institution there in another
institution anyway so we created this
rapid rapid cycle for actually sharing
the data and from being able to still
analyze it so while others might also be
able to analyze the data you the idea
would that there would be more data than
one individual could possibly collect
and then let me just add a little bit on
that spiel is that who owns that data
set these data sets are sitting on
people's hard drives of sitting in
institutional offices and they've been
paid for by the public when we think
about the National Science Foundation
and the money that goes into research
and then it gets duplicated again and
again and it's not an efficient use of
resources we're not actually being able
to move the system as quickly as we can
so when we think about data sets it's
long been held tight just for the
reasons you described but if you can
imagine if we create incentives to open
that up and to acknowledge that faculty
member as a contributor then we can
really move the ball in a significant
way thank you question over here over
this way
hi there hi um care installment from the
University of Michigan I wanted to thank
you for bringing open out into the open
in this discussion because I think we
have a language issue between
asynchronous online electronic education
and the true global good that is an open
educational resource and the one thing I
would also encourage us to recognize is
that it's a two-way street and so the
challenge that many of us face in a
highly westernized and highly resource
rich environment is the risk of
colonialization right and i can tell you
that i have personally benefited from
having all of my MOOC in an open
educational resource and a Creative
Commons license and having the
opportunity to learn from other people
around the globe about their best
practices and I live in a medical
education environment and a healthcare
environment and so it's really humbling
to recognize that you don't have to keep
it for yourself because there are
millions of people who are just as smart
and just as capable and as excited as we
are about this space so I just wanted to
say thank you yeah well so let me ask
you a question that are there any
downsides that you experience to opening
your content the downside was in the
preparation and making sure that
everything was a copyright clean so
making sure that i went to the Creative
Commons license space or if there were
images that I wanted to use that I made
sure they were clean the other thing
that's a challenge that i found was
providing online educational resources
because obviously some people don't have
access to the libraries that we do or if
you quote an article or a textbook they
can't just download it for free so
making sure that any references i used i
actually obtained from an open site so
that it could stay open was important in
my design that's great all right very
helpful thank you
hi I'm I'm Sasha akbari from cayuga
community college actually met you
before my question is we did a MOOC for
developmental education in in math like
really really basic pre-algebra stuff
and one of the challenges we went into
it thinking oh there's going to be a ER
for this all over the place and there
there was some great content very little
of that content was designed for our
audience so a lot of that content that
you all in this room probably use all
the time is fantastic content much
higher level content then we could use
and then there's also a lot at the k-12
level right so there's a lot of the k-12
level but it's not really designed for a
non-traditional learner and because the
reach of what we could we can do at the
community college level is is so huge
but it's also like a non-networked
audience so our audience doesn't go
about finding about a MOOC by going to
EDX are going to Coursera we were
explaining to people what a MOOC is and
and sometimes we're having that
conversation institutionally what is a
MOOC why are we doing a MOOC what can a
MOOC do for us so my question is do you
know of any efforts in order to
translate some of the content you know
that the remix ting process Andrey
publishing process is so time intensive
and I didn't know if there were any
initiatives you knew about or any kind
of projects moving forward that's
looking at taking the fantastic content
and like breaking it down so that it
would be for a less traditional sort of
you know someone who already has a
master's green is going back to get some
of that you know additional professional
development all right so I think you've
kind of hit the nail on one of the
challenges that some of the content
isn't yet even easily discoverable when
it carries a Creative Commons license
and that was partly a decision early on
from the Creative Commons that actually
the Internet is the commons it's the
public place where content lives and at
that time they weren't walled gardens so
we expected that the search engines
would actually make it easy to retrieve
she could go to google and you go to an
advanced search you can actually search
for creative common
licensed content so it makes it easier
to find but we haven't completely solved
that problem and I remember where I met
you in DC I believe and and I'm going to
point you also to Paul Stacy of Creative
Commons so you've probably worked with
because there is a fair amount of
content there and there is targeted to
different audiences but instead of
always having to start from scratch if
you could take some of that content and
actually tweak it for your particular
audience I should also say that's a lot
of movement in the united states around
the k-12 and the Common Core because the
Common Core now creates a spine where
you can actually map the oer content to
the objectives student the learning
objectives and so I think we're going to
be seeing particularly in math and
sciences an early release of oer content
that then again because of the power of
it is you don't have to start from
scratch you can take it and build on it
from there so their math has been around
for a long time I think actually Paul
would probably be able to identify most
of the resources and I just want to
acknowledge Paul Stacey who's part of
the education team at Creative Commons a
longtime colleague and supporter of oh
yah from his early days in British
Columbia who's a fount of knowledge
about this as well I want to first of
all thank you for your work in this area
I think of all the discussions here this
is the most important one it's the only
one where it's a question of if and not
when and I really appreciate this I had
a question about legal frameworks
Creative Commons was a wonderful
framework a decade ago it started to
fray a little bit with oli where there
was open content at a closed platform so
in fact could not reuse it it started to
fray very heavily go from fraying
through almost collapsing and MOOCs
where things like graters things like
that simply having access to a MOOC
doesn't mean you can pull the content
out or use it and remix it there are a
lot of more nuanced issues such as can I
take your course and set up a website
that does give students answer soon as
it's moving from low stakes and high
stakes assessments from things like
videos to things like studded projects
great assignments exams the legal
frameworks really haven't kept up do you
know if there's an
should've to update the legal frameworks
or askew lit working on this problem yes
so I think that's a very valid point so
just from the legal framework side even
in the Creative Commons side we just
versioned up to four point oh of a
license and so part of that was because
the licenses were being ported into each
country and it still meant it could be
shared and the license has been held
valid in court of law across countries
but it wasn't it was a little messy and
it didn't deal with data well so
creative commons went through a two-year
versioning process with a global
community and they've come up with the
international license that now spans
across the globe and it deals with tsui
generous rights and data which is
particularly a European issue so that's
just some that's part of the continued
evolution of the licenses always has to
evolve on the data side Candice and I
have had some conversations about this
one of the most recent ones when she
came and asked me to participate in this
meeting was we were both sitting there
saying how did we make the mistake in
some ways with that early grant to oli
like why don't we think about the open
source platform because we were focused
on the content and we both agree that we
couldn't then have seen where we are now
that's just kind of a reality that we
were trying to focus on the learning
design and even you'll it as a
foundation didn't have it as a process
to figure out how to write in its grants
about requiring things be made open
educational resources within our grant
process early in the days of oer i would
have faculty other institutions say
you've got to change your letter and
make sure it requires a university keep
this open because otherwise folks at the
university will try to clamp it down so
there's been a whole process get going
to that question of constraints about
what it means we now know just what you
described that if the content is open
but you can't move it if it's not
interoperable if you can't move it to
another platform then it's open access
in many ways right and so now how do we
blend those worlds together Candice is
working on that at Stanford she's
working to bring that and her piece to
open EDX as well and then the last part
of your question is around assessments
which has been
another conversation so part of the
conversation is now this move towards
open assessments sometimes the Sussman's
are going to have to be held so that the
public doesn't have them those tend to
be the high stakes assessments even when
we heard Susan this morning we also
heard a lot of emphasis on the formative
assessment that immediate feedback but
we can create other assessments and
there's actually a project that ulit has
funded for a competitive system about
creating open assessments so I think
you're beginning to see some movement in
that space and I think the question is
is how we take all these different
elements and how we blend them to create
a coherent system that is seamless and
interoperable so I guess stay tuned and
continue to be a supporter and help us
on that problem I may say yeah I'm sorry
actually mark lester from futurelearn
just in the middle to the right of the
camera yes hi there uh again thank you
very much as you mentioned futurelearn
was founded by the British Open
University so there's a strong
commitment to to openness um I thought
the first thing I wanted to say was just
a clarification which is actually we do
permit universities to publish the
materials under a Creative Commons
license on the platform so that feature
is there you'll be pleased to know in
sort they will be making a wall art
delivered content that means the videos
articles that they will be open
shareable and discoverable okay so I
hope that's a useful contribution to
this but one of the challenges that our
universities obviously face is and it's
been mentioned here already securing
high-quality content that's usually
locked up in licensing is there anything
that you're working on with anybody else
or we can all do to try and free up more
of that content because I think that's a
huge barrier to to some of the goals I
think we all have so on the quality
content I know openlearn has been in the
UK has been really one of the early
design was about really the high quality
content so I would say that the world
has changed and content content is
everywhere and so my take on this is
that it continue we continue to do
so use resources to develop similar
content content will differ it needs to
evolve it needs to be maintained it
needs to be corrected as Pluto a planet
or not but we don't always have to start
from scratch right we've got like every
state developing an algebra class
algebra hasn't changed that much we can
use those resources for teachers we can
use it for students we can use it for
the some of the data mining right so one
of the questions is how does the
community feel about coming together and
sharing that content and what would that
look like I mean so you know and there's
also a business model because I don't
think everyone can continue to develop
the highest quality content because it's
very expensive oh you UK was the highest
by far and what they spent per cost I
know it was like a five-year cycle and
the content you know the way the faculty
SAT around very very high quality so in
this new age what does it mean and is
the value proposition around the
creation of the content or around some
of the other norms of support and
certification and credentialing and so I
don't have an answer to that I might you
know our answer Mike's answer and I
early in the early days is we wanted to
create up a switching station right we
wanted to create a pool where people
would all contribute and say hey I've
developed this and let me put it in and
you've developed that let me use what
you have but we still have this instinct
not to use what someone else is created
because if I create it myself it will be
better I say it again if I create it
myself it will be better and we don't
know that there's no empirical evidence
to that so we need to share what we call
it what we develop as a group will be
better I think we can all say that for
sure and so if there's some energy
around this happy to brainstorm on some
ideas gentleman here my question is
about with all this content around and
in open educational resources but when I
read the National Research Council
things they're all saying you should use
research based content it's much more
you should you breeze use research
pedagogy is much more effective how do
we get from where we have this huge
library of quality educational resources
developed largely by people who are
ignorant of the education research
literature and techniques how do we get
from there to where people are actually
using stuff that is demonstrated to be
efficacious by my research right and i
think so i think that's exactly the
right question and i think that's the
right question whether it's open or not
right how do we get everyone to use the
content that is of research quality and
I think that's this very much the same
in the oer see I think the content the
little will create system so that we can
actually we need to do more efficacy
studies we have some coming out of the
open research hub which is actually at
the oh you UK and that will be released
in the early 2015 but we also need to
understand to build that research much
more and then let the community to kind
of like bump off what's really effective
and kind of let us get rid of content
that isn't working effectively if we can
share it more readily we can also access
it and teachers and faculty can use that
much more readily there's a whole
culture though and you know I say this
at MIT sitting in front of a lecture
hall is that you know the reason a
lecture hall created was wasn't for
pedagogical efficacy it was because it
was a way to scale a one-to-one tutoring
or a small tutoring session which is it
to say that a large lecture halls and
effective sometimes but how do I know I
even been effective in this talk where's
the research data about that we continue
to replicate these very traditional
norms well we now have the opportunity
with the computational power with the
data mining to really refine it so then
the question is how do we actually
refine it how do we get people to
understand and to use it and how do we
spread that as a no um when Chuck vest
came to you live with the MIT
OpenCourseWare it wasn't just about
opening the window so people could peer
into MIT it was fundamentally and he
always spoke about this it was about
improving teaching and learning it was
always at the core that he wants
bring that back to MIT and while he was
doing that he was also helping to serve
the mission of MIT and so I think in
this way in the efficacy studies in the
research I think wherever Susan is she
has a lot of work on her agenda around
how do we use NSF Dallas to really
continue to push this as well oh okay
very good thank you so before you leave
I won't say little bit about what we
have arranged for you for tonight so we
have this amazing program arranged at
John F Kennedy Museum it's a really
unique place in New England so if you
haven't been there you'd come and at the
beginning we have a reception for all of
you to get to know each other the quick
hits you submitted we will have a
presenter there and also to help all the
communicate we have some drink tickets
so you can actually we have this process
in there followed that we have a really
great panel set up that have announced
from erics and with a girl from co Sarah
Melissa log from canvas mark lester from
futurelearn moderated by diana oplinger
from education I think that will be
probably a great highlight for this
entire conference this is the place that
you can ask all these questions you want
to ask from these people and hopefully
they will give you great answers so that
would be very interesting panel and that
followed by another New England icon
will have a clambake so if you haven't
signed up for dinner we have but I think
10 tickets left so first come first
serve basis you can go purchase
etiquette from the counter I don't want
to leave any tickets add purchase so so
I hope to see you all and the buses will
start leaving your promptly starting at
five so make sure we have the sessions
are in ended and then
and the buses will be out in the front
so don't miss the bus if you miss the
bus it's a horrific commute to get to
JFK museum